will the mcu's newest overarching
villain look different in their next
installment with the troubling news
regarding actor Jonathan Majors it
certainly seems likely the role will be
recast for me a month after kangna
conqueror was debuted keep watching to
find out all of the details on Saturday
March 25th Majors was arrested in New
York after a domestic dispute with a 30
year old woman whom TMZ claims as the
actor's girlfriend the victim received
minor injuries while Majors was placed
under arrest on charges of assault
harassment and strangulation Jonathan
Majors representative says the actor is
not guilty of the ACT telling the
Associated Press he has done nothing
wrong we look forward to clearing his
name and clearing this up on the
afternoon of Sunday March 26 criminal
defense lawyer Priya Chaudhry told
variety Jonathan Major's innocence will
be proven through video evidence and his
team expects charges to be dropped
entirely and imminently Mages has been
one of the industry's fastest rising
talents with notable projects under his
belts such as the five Bloods The Harder
They Fall and most recently Creed 3.
perhaps most noteworthy of these is
Major's role in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as a franchise's new main
antagonist Kang the Conqueror along with
his many variants as the new Big Bad of
the MCU Majors Kang was expected to have
a heavy presence in phases 5 and 6.
despite the actor's team claiming his
innocence and the dispute this shocking
news could shake up the MCU entirely
especially if Majors isn't entirely
Vindicated introducing the Disney plus
series Loki as Kang variant he who
remains and later showing up as Kung the
Conqueror for the film Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania Jonathan Major's
appearance in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe was meant to unleash a new
breed of Terror to the franchise more
the character gave Scott Lang a run for
his money in Quantum Mania his true
impact on the future of the mcu's phases
5 and 6 has yet to be seen as the
mid-credits scene to the third Ant-Man
reveals a countless number of variants
preparing to start a multiversal
uprising this is only meant to be a sign
of things to come as near the end of
phase six we'll be seeing Kang take on
Earth's Mightiest Heroes as a titular
adversary in Avengers the Kang Dynasty
should Mages be found guilty of his
abused allegations however we probably
won't see him back in the MCU again
while the long-running franchise hadn't
seen much in the way of actor
controversy beforehand the Studio's
firing of such key figures as longtime
producer Victoria Alonso for contract
breaching suggests that the company
takes us legal matters very seriously
additionally Disney cut ties with James
Gunn in 2018 after offensive tweets
resurfaced but the director was brought
back on a year later but even if Majors
is out of the picture that doesn't mean
it's the end for Kang Jonathan Majors
assault charges could very well close
the curtain on the actor's time in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe however the
character of Kang can still thrive in
the franchise's future as mentioned
earlier the mid-credit scene of antsman
and the WASP Quantum Mania reveals
Kang's endless Army of variance while
some may already be used to seeing Mages
as a power hungry antagonist it's
possible that another actor could
replace Mages in the role with relative
ease as another variant remember that
Kangol having been an Infamous member of
Marvel's extensive Rogue gallery for
decades is a new addition to the MCU as
audiences are still growing accustomed
to the character and his abilities
having it explain that Kang's variants
could take on entirely different forms
could work without being too jarring now
this time the only Kung variants we've
seen have all been played by Majors but
it definitely doesn't have to stay this
way if Marvel Studios needs a believable
way out that's proven in low-key
variants of a character don't have to
look remotely the same or be the same
species for that matter so it wouldn't
be the mcu's first time taking this
approach simply recasting Majors with
another actor would be the easiest and
cheapest way out time will tell how this
troubling scenario progresses but the
MCU certainly has options should they
need them if you or someone you know is
struggling with domestic abuse please
call or chat online with a National
Domestic violence hotline that's
1-800-799-7233
foreign